in this series i'm going to surprise you
i'm going to strip away all the
complexity and hard craft and teach you
how to cook amazing food standing on
your head that is amazing incredibly
tender from the kitchen novice to the
budding chef i'm going to give you the
confidence the recipes and the insider
knowledge to make you a much better cook
slice round
wasting nothing
i made my name cooking in some of the
world's most demanding kitchens
that's nice you're making my difficult
service yeah in my restaurants i expect
perfection every play has to be worthy
of a michelin star and every time you
make you taste it as well every day
changes
now i'm going to show you some simple
and accessible recipes for fantastic
food that you can cook easily at home
incredible i'll be holding you by the
hand just getting better and better and
better
teaching you everything from how to cook
on a budget to baking real fast food and
my ultimate feast recipes this is the
only cookery course you'll ever need
welcome to my ultimate cookery course
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stake your life on right
this is my guide to cooking with spice
adding big gutsy flavors using spices at
the beginning of cooking and then simply
letting the dish slow cook is a
brilliant way of getting maximum flavor
with minimal effort
my first recipe melts in the mouth and
because the oven does most of the work
it's a cinch to make slow cooked fiery
lamb
cooking's all about being bold and
adventurous and this dish is exciting
because it's slowly cooked and the
longer it cooks the more flavoursome it
becomes
marinating the lamb first chilis we're
going to use a mixture of red and green
take off the tops
and just slice
in
garlic
crushed
don't worry about chopping these ultra
fine just
get it in there
cooking
for up to three hours
everything sort of blends and almost
sort of
purees itself together
smoked paprika goes brilliantly well
with the chilis two teaspoons in
a touch of dried oregano
some little cumin seeds the blend and
the fragrance that they give out is
extraordinary they release a little oil
as well and helps to tenderize the lamb
a touch of salt
pepper
cinnamon
that sort of sweetens up the lamb
olive oil
just a tablespoon and the olive oil
helps to sort of stick all those
wonderful spices to the lamb jump in
just start really rubbing at this stage
you can leave the lamb to marinade for
anything from half an hour to overnight
allowing the spices to really penetrate
the meat giving amazing results when you
tuck in delicious
vegetables carrots and onions and that's
it sliced
secret slicing vegetables for braising
is not getting too thin you slice the
onions too thin they burn you've got
that horrible char taste on that slow
braised braising it's just a chef's term
that means cooking in liquid on a low
heat making the meat incredibly moist
and beautifully tender so the secret of
braising is having a really nice thick
durable pan
get that nice and hot
just a touch of olive oil
lamb in hold the bone
because you're in control then into the
pan
i want that white fat to start rendering
so it'll add more fat therefore making
it a lot more flavoursome as it braises
chilies
cinnamon
in
mix that up
and don't be scared you're not burning
this you're sort of searing the lamb
shanks and this is the important part
right at the very beginning we're going
to the collar on the lamb which washes
off as it braises in the oven so
be generous with that color
vegetables in
wow and then a couple of baileys so now
you lift the lamb up
and get the lamb
sat
on top of the vegetables
now just glaze the pan with red wine
the glazing means that you're you're
cleaning the bottom of the pan and
you're getting that amazing flavor
washed off and lifted up into that sauce
can really transform that dish always
delays
then bring to the boil and cook for
about 10 minutes to reduce the wine's
reduced down by half now for the stock
bring that stock back up to the ball and
then into the oven now don't cover it
when you cover it all the condensation
comes off the lid your lamb becomes gray
all this effort and that exciting spice
gets washed away no lid and in the oven
for three hours
a slow cook on a low heat of 160 degrees
gives the spices time to work and
transform the meat so it's
mouthwateringly tender
now
look at those
out on to a plate you can just see that
meat sliding down
juicy and incredibly tender grab it by
the
the shank rolling around that rich
delicious sauce
look at that
and get your sauce
nice
beautiful
just get some mint
don't chop it
just pick that fresh mint and let it
snow and there you go a very spicy
delicious melting of the mouth lamb
shank amazing
to get the most out of your spices
there's only one piece of kit that you
need pestle and water i mean they look
fantastic and it's essential for any
good kitchen these things are so
versatile these ancient kitchen tools
are perfect for everything from pestos
to dressings and cost them around 15
quid
use the grind spices and you'll max out
on flavor get perfect textures and
always be totally in control
make sure you've got a nice large
circumference of the bowl
so you can grind away the heavier the
more durable they are the more
confidence it gives you when you're
pounding and there's almost a way of
confirming
homemade hand pounded
grab yourself a pestle and mortar and
soon you'll be spicing with ease
spices are a brilliant way to add an
extra layer and a depth of complexity to
any dish learning to use them properly
will really improve your cooking here
are three more of my super simple spice
recipes to get you going
[Music]
first up a very easy chilli and spice
white bait
start with the spice coating
szechuan peppercorns and coriander seeds
in a hot dry pan to release their
flavours
[Music]
add chili flakes and grinder pestle and
water to make a fiery fine powder
combine with plain flour season and mix
[Music]
add olive oil to a hot pan
coat white bait in the spicy flour mix
then fry
white bait are an oily fish that are
healthy delicious and cooking minutes
once golden they're done
fantastic with garlic mayonnaise or a
simple squeeze of lemon
[Music]
ready in under 10 minutes chili and
spice white bait an easy simple spicy
dish
[Music]
my next amazingly aromatic recipe is
roasted squash hummus
[Music]
start with my take on rasal hanut a
classic moroccan spice blend
in a dry pan toast cinnamon cloves
coriander
fenugreek and fennel seeds
then add mustard seeds and cumin
when the seeds start to pop they're
ready
add paprika and grind into a fine powder
for the hummus
peel and chop butternut squash
put on a baking tray and add garlic
simply bashed and chopped ginger
drizzle with olive oil season and
sprinkle over the spice mix
then roast in a hot oven for half an
hour until soft
allow to cool and place in a blender
add tahini a nutty paste made from
sesame seeds cooked chickpeas
a dash of lemon juice
and a drizzle of olive oil
blitz until luxuriously creamy and
textured
spices toasted for maximum flavor
amazing roasted squash hummus
my final deliciously spicy dish is
curry spice sweet corn soup
[Music]
first the fragrant curry paste
roast coriander and cumin seeds until
aromatic
then grind adding crushed garlic chili
powder turmeric and finely chopped
ginger
[Music]
bring together with olive oil to form a
thick paste
for the soup fry finely chopped onions
in olive oil
add the curry paste and cook to release
the flavors
add cubed potatoes chicken stock
and season
when the potato has softened stir in
cream corn
[Music]
then add whole sweet corn kernels with
some of the juices
and transfer to a blender and blitz
until smooth
for texture add more whole sweet corn
heat and it's ready to serve
[Music]
wonderfully satisfying carried spice
sweet corn soup that packs an amazingly
aromatic punch
three more stunning recipes that make
cooking with spice simple
incredible
[Music]
this is my guide to cooking with spice
next up my shopping guide to buying
spices
[Music]
when i buy my spice i only want the best
and it always pays to get expert advice
berget aerith has been selling every
spice under the sun in london's not a
hill for over 20 years so she really
knows what she's talking about i love
spices the smell the texture the color
spices are so versatile something very
very simple can be really transformed
into something really delicious with
thousands of aromatic ingredients on her
shelves if it smells good she sells it
if you buy spices buy them whole then
you can try roast them grind them when
you need them and then they will release
the essential oils whole spices you can
keep for years give them a good bashing
wine bottle with your rolling pin or
whatever and you see there is still
aroma and you can taste it you smell it
then it's fine
there's four main spices one is sweet
one is sour one is bitter and one is hot
this is cinnamon and that is really a
great example of a sweet spice when you
buy a cinnamon quill like this you have
to check that you have loads of
different layers in here then you can
either grind this or you'd break a piece
off i mean this doesn't smell of
anything now
but if you roll it in your hand just
quickly like this
and then you smell it again this is just
unbelievable if you have spaghetti
bolognese put a pinch of cinnamon in it
to bring out the flavor
so monk this is one of those
really special spices sour like a lemon
but it has a salty aftertaste i use this
anywhere from marinades to salad you
haven't lived unless you tried it a
great example for a bitter spice would
actually be a turmeric this is actually
a root it grows in the ground like
ginger use it very very sparingly about
that much will actually color you a
curry
or rice dish wonderful yellow watch your
fingers you get really yellow fingers
from it and then we come to the hot
spices one spice that i couldn't miss
and that is hungarian paprika paprika
is the powdery form of a bell pepper
what makes the hungarian paprika
different is that they actually crowd in
vineyards it's sort of between the vines
it has a sweetness and it has
a sharpness to it i have it in ice cream
i have it on fish i have it everywhere
burger spot on about the power of spices
to transform dishes whether savory or
sweet
here's my quick guide to the spices i
use most
black pepper this is the spice i
couldn't do without always buy a whole
and grind yourself so you get the
freshest flavor
cardamom these pods come in green or
black types and have a fantastic spicy
sweet taste brilliant for everything
from curries to rice dishes and puddings
coriander these citrusy seeds are
perfect hole in pickles or grind to use
in fragrance stews and soups
cumin a savory spice that's pungent and
nutty it's great in marinades for
delicious meat and fish
then cinnamon
sweetly fragrant and great with apples
or in cakes
and nutmeg warm and spicy it's delicious
and a vegetable sauce
finely saffron these sweet strands
infuse a brilliant bright red color and
are great in risottos and even though
it's more expensive than gold a pinch
goes a long long way
store your spices properly and they'll
last for years you keep it airtight in a
tin or in a glass jar in your cupboard
don't be scared of spices like
an aftershave or perfume you have to
select it yourself it has to fit in with
your taste and with your kitchen
supermarkets and good local shops sell
an amazing array of different spices so
there's no excuse for not being
adventurous be bold find what you like
and spice up your cooking
like all chefs i love the challenge of
transforming classic recipes giving them
a new twist to make them modern and
vibrant
to keep old dishes fresh and exciting
it's great to get spicy
my next recipe is a time-honored british
classic but with addition of spices it's
given a new lease of life fragrant
spiced rice pudding
i love cooking with spices but you don't
have to just cook savory dishes using
aromatics and spices across desserts
takes your puddings to a completely
different level
[Music]
first off our spices this is a fresh
banana pot fragrant
and packed full of flavour use the back
of the knife and flatten it that removes
all those little seeds
off the skin of the vanilla pod take
your knife
slice down the middle
and then when you open that up the smell
is incredible
take the tip of the knife and you scrape
inside and look
all those seeds
dying to come out that is incredible
there are thousands of seeds still
ingrained to the pod so put them
in
to the casserole cardamom
powerful
spicy
take two little pods
place your knife on top
lightly crack them cracking the cardamom
pods helps release all the amazing
flavor cloves
gives it that kind of
aniseed
flavor with a lot of depth
one
two three
cinnamon stick
snap and in just smelling that level of
fragrance you can imagine what the rice
pudding is gonna taste of turn on the
heat lightly toast those spices just a
couple of seconds now what's gonna
happen is just gonna sort of enhance
those spices in a way that it just draws
out an even more powerful fragrance
coconut milk in
sugar
two tablespoons
milk
and then a couple of tablespoons of
cream
bring it slowly to the boil to allow the
flavours to infuse and this rice pudding
reminds me of my time in india where i
got really into that chai tea fragrance
because it was just so delicious
and so comforting
take a lime
in
the lime just cuts through the richness
of the coconut gives it that nice little
bit of acidity goes fantastically well
with the cinnamon and that fresh vanilla
nice have a taste
now let's come up to the boil give it a
nice little clean around the outside
and in with the rice
use 200 grams of pudding rice don't wash
it beforehand because the starch helps
thicken the rice pudding in the oven
and just turn that down to a light
simmer and the pudding rice starts to
open up and it absorbs all that coconut
vanilla
cardamom clove and cinnamon bring up to
the ball gently and cook it out three to
five minutes
boiling it rapidly the rice opens up and
it goes into mush we want to keep that
nice texture that sort of fragrant rice
pudding on a gentle simmer
next a little luxury
i want to show you how
i take this simple delicious aromatic
rice pudding to a completely different
level here's what i do
take
two egg yolks separate them
now give that a really nice
whisk
two nice tablespoons of mascarpone
cheese
whisk that into the egg yolks
just so it's nice and smooth
it's almost like finishing the rice
pudding in a delicious custard turn off
the gas add that
into the rice pudding what happens it
starts to enrich and really thicken this
rice pudding and takes it to a
completely different level
the rice is still not cooked it's
starting to go nice and soft you can
just see how it's opening up
but looks like rich aromatic lava
bubbling away
finally great more citrus zest the lime
on top
roasted
caramelized lime zest on top of a rice
pudding
is phenomenal
then put it in the oven for 15 minutes
at 200 degrees to finish cooking the
rice and develop the intensely aromatic
flavors
look at that
an incredibly fragrant
rice pudding how beautiful does that
look
spices are a brilliant way of helping
classic dishes come alive
i'll guarantee you'll never ever have
had a rice pudding like this before
next my tricks of the trade and kitchen
tips
first how to zest the lemon
the important part is not to zest any of
the pith
watch the following technique and i'll
show you how
we've got these original graters really
important when we use this we use the
the fine zester not the big rough one
not the one for slicing and not the
other one for grating this
little one here onto a plate because
it's always easier to lift off from the
plate than it is of the board and the
most important thing about zesting a
lemon is
nice long strokes
but twisting
the lemon round every time we go down we
twist
same with the orange and same with the
lime
little tap
if you go too far
let me just show you
look you got that white bitter piff that
destroys the wonderful zesty flavor and
look that's what we're looking for there
this really nice vibrant
lemon zest
delicious
garlic is a key ingredient in so many
spicy dishes my tip for finally chopping
a mincing is add a pinch of salt for
abrasion which helps break the fibers of
the garlic down for a much better result
for getting the most out of root ginger
simply remove the skin using a teaspoon
it's easier than using a knife and you
can get around the tricky bits or just
keep the skin on and give it a good wash
never throw out vanilla pods there's a
ton of flavor left in the skin stick
inside jars of sugar and leave to infuse
great to sprinkle on cakes biscuits or
porridge
when grinding up spices if you have any
leftover you can store in an airtight
jar for up to two months great for a
spicy kick to have at your fingertips
follow my ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips
and 100 recipes to stake your life on
and you'll literally be cooking yourself
into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stake your life on
right now it's all about cooking with
chili
[Music]
for me chilis are an incredible
ingredient in the cook's arsenal capable
of transforming dishes adding excitement
heat and a wonderful taste i'm going to
show you how to get the grips with their
intense flavor
first up
red mullet with sweet chili sauce
cooking is about being adventurous and
having the confidence to go off piste
and being a little bit more daring so
when you start combining peanuts chili
flakes and this amazing fish red mullet
trust me you're in for an amazing treat
we're gonna make a really nice light
sweet chili sauce
first off your chili
off with the top
in half
and those seeds inside
are very powerful
incredibly
hot
but full of flavor
garlic
two cloves of garlic
slice the garlic nice and thin
so it helps to puree
the chilies in the pest and water garlic
in
such a salt a little touch
of sugar
in
and then start grinding
push down first
[Music]
the salt and the sugar
really helps to puree the chili
and the garlic
fish sauce always a base
to a chili sauce two tablespoons in
and a touch of rice wine vinegar
fish sauce gives it the saltiness the
vinegar gives it a nice acidic wake up
three tablespoons
of olive oil
nice
mix that up
beautiful look at it the colors
incredible
now spring onions i want the texture
and the crunch spring onions in
the coriander slice it once
in
fresh lime
and that goes brilliantly with a red
mullet just really wakes up the chili
the garlic and reminds the sauce that
we're serving with fish now taste
wow that's delicious look at that
beautiful
the longer that chili sauce sits there
the better it gets now for the peanuts
and chili that's going to coat the top
of the red mullet
peanuts in
salt
in that helps to really grind the
peanuts down some beautiful dried chili
flakes creates a nice sort of warm
heat i'm using fresh chili for the sauce
but dried chili flakes for the coating
which will really crunch up when cooking
just a little bit of
coriander mix the coriander in
to the peanuts
and look i like them quite textured i
don't want them too small as a powder
otherwise they'll burn but crushed
lightly
to coat the fish with the chili and
peanut seasoning in a separate bowl beat
two eggs along with a splash of fish
sauce
take your fillet
lay
in your red mullet
dip it in
shake up your peanuts
and then in and make sure you push that
down cover that red mullet
up beautiful
now make sure that pan is really nice
and piping on if you put the fish in and
the pan's cold
all those wonderful peanuts and chilli
just gonna slide off the fish so we need
to sear it in and get it nice and crisp
in and lay away from you
beautiful
[Music]
if the pan starts getting a little bit
too hot
get your olive oil
and just place another teaspoon of olive
oil around the outside so it starts to
heat up as it hits the center and it
really helps to stay so much more in
control
and turn
nice and gently
we want that nice sort of toasted
sauteed
crispness
which adds a really lovely flavor
tilt the pan
and just baste the top of the red mullet
with that really nice piping hot olive
oil
you've got that really nice roasted
crunch and it goes brilliantly with that
soft sweetness of that fish inside
get off
and just leave them sitting in there
and finish with lime and just go over
each one
now we'll take them out
and the sauce
will touch on the bottom
and the tail of each fish
now to round that off
serving some fragrant rice
sauteed broccoli
amazing and there you have a delicious
peanut and crusted red mullet with a
wonderful sweet chilli sauce cooking
with chilis isn't all about blow your
head off heat this dish uses the
exciting taste of a chili but has a
deliciously elegant and subtle flavor
you become more confident using chili's
you'll find they can transform your
cooking chilis are a great way of making
dishes exciting and vibrant here are
three quick recipes that are full of
flavor and come with a kick
first up pasta with tomatoes anchovies
and chilies
[Music]
for the spicy sauce slice anchovies
and garlic
next dried chilies great for keeping in
the cupboard to add a hit of heat on
demand
[Music]
then add the anchovy oil to a hot pan
and fry the chopped ingredients
add half cherry tomatoes
[Music]
chopped black olives and salty capers
cooked to combine the flavors
in a separate pan boiled dried spaghetti
another great store-covered staple
when the pasta is tender but still firm
drain
add to the sauce with a splash of the
water it's full of starch which gives a
great silky consistency
then season with pepper and topped with
basil
packed with big bold flavors and ready
in under 20 minutes pasta with tomatoes
anchovy and chilis
my next deliciously different chili
recipe
is grilled corn with chipotle chili
butter
[Music]
first the topping chopped coriander
then add softened butter
soak chipotle chilies in hot water these
are dried jalapenos which have an
amazing smoky flavor
drain and chop
[Music]
mix together and season
[Music]
next fry corn on the cob in olive oil
you want a really wonderfully charred
flavor
when colored add water to steam through
[Music]
to eat smother the cobs in the butter
and crumble over lancashire cheese
fantastically messy to eat grilled corn
with chipotle chili butter and utterly
delicious smoky treat
my final recipe is a chili classic
jerk chicken
[Music]
start by making the intense jerk
marinade
first scotch bonnet chilis they may be
small but pack real heat and a fruity
punch
then chop garlic
and fresh thyme
[Music]
for spice add ground cloves
cinnamon
nutmeg and allspice
season with salt and pepper and combine
with olive oil
[Music]
next score chicken legs so the hot spicy
flavors get deep inside the meat
rub thoroughly with the jerk mix and
marinade
and olive oil to a hot dish
[Music]
brown the marinaded chicken for 10
minutes
then add worcestershire sauce
cover and cook in the oven at 220
degrees for 20 minutes
[Music]
hot spicy jerk chicken easy to make and
finger licking good
three different chilis
three amazing flavors
three irresistible dishes
nice
[Music]
next five more of my 100 tips that will
make your life easier in the kitchen
first up how to de-seed chili
to get the seeds out hold it upright and
just rub
the chili between your hands the seeds
are incredibly hot you're just releasing
them from the inside
tapping it down
and then again just a final little rub
now cut the top off
and then
just open up
and look
they come out like little miniature
smarties
from there
cut the little bottom bit off
amazing
next a great tip for using spare chilis
using string tie together the stalks
then simply hang in your kitchen in just
a few weeks you'll get your very own
dried chilies great crumbled into dishes
for adding heat on demand
chilies are surprisingly versatile if
you love them in savory dishes my tip is
to try adding them to melty chocolate
ganache for chocolate chili truffles or
sprinkled over fresh fruit like mango or
watermelon
a great tip to prevent burning sensitive
skin when working with chilies to get
rid of that spice and that heat on your
fingers a little bit of lemon squeeze a
little bit of lemon juice and that
instantly gets rid of the heat fresh
lemon juice
spice up your drinks for a mexican twist
add a dash of hot chili sauce to beer or
using cocktails to give your drink a
very different sort of kick
this is my ultimate cookery course 100
recipes to stake your life on i'll be
showing you an amazing spicy beef salad
take a little teaspoon of your dressing
and just go over the beef
but first the secret to cooking
fantastic food is to start with great
ingredients the more you know personally
about where your ingredients are from
and how they produce the better so don't
be scared ask lots of questions and
learn
and when it comes to chilis there's no
one better to ask than chili grower
joanna plum who's been farming chili's
from mild to mind-blown for over 11
years i eat chilies all the time every
single day she grows over 60 types on
her farm and really knows her poblanos
from a habaneros
people think that chili's are all about
heat actually it's about flavor as well
some are sweet
some are aromatic and they can be used
in so many different dishes when you go
shopping and you're looking for a chili
what should you be looking for what you
want to do is look at the chili and it
needs to be nice and firm and glossy
generally the bigger the chili the
milder it's going to be the smaller the
chilli the hotter and if it's small and
wrinkly like this one it's going to blow
your socks off another way to tell if a
chilli is hot or not is to split it open
and smell it
if it's a super hot chili
it'll clear your sinuses
the heat of a chili comes from an oil
called capsaicin and that is
concentrated mainly at the top of the
chili where the seeds are now when
you're cooking with a chili and you want
the flavour of the chili but not too
much of the heat start with just using
the bottom of it
as you get closer to the seeds that
chili's going to get hotter
so if you remove the seeds that also
does remove some of the heat there's
thousands of varieties out there because
they cross pollinate very very easily
and that's why the world's hottest chili
is always changing
joanna's right with over 200 types
available all with different flavors
aromas and of course levels of heat it's
important to buy what you like here are
my top chilis whatever your desired kick
at the mild end poblano these are great
for stuffing have a delicate flavor and
often used in mexican dishes
starting to get hot the jalapeno when
they're green they're like spicy bell
pepper the redder they are the sweeter
they are
bird's eye where they really start to
pack a punch long thin and pungent
they're great in thai dishes and are
often green or red and at the top end
the habanero these lantern shaped demons
have a delicious fruity taste and
they're the firecracker of the chili
world
another way to use chilies is to smoke
them and to make chipotle
what it is it's just a mesquite smoked
red jalapeno
it smells fantastic you can
almost get that like smoky bacon sort of
flavor out of it so you would use this
in anything that you would slow cook
so you're eating a chili and it's really
too hot for you the best way to get rid
of that heat is to drink some milk or a
dairy product like yoghurt whatever you
do don't go for water or for beer
don't be frightened of trying new types
of chilies in your cooking experimenting
with these amazing fiery beasts is a
great excuse for getting hot-headed in
the kitchen
they give you a natural high much like
when you've been exercising so your
endorphins are released and you just
feel good chilies make you happy and
they're also an aphrodisiac
[Music]
southeast asian chefs they're brilliant
at balancing the hot spices of chili
with sweet sour and salty flavors
if you want a new twist on a favorite
dish spice it up with chili
my next recipe is super simple to make
but has wonderful depth and complexity
of flavors spicy beef salad
chilies if you use them confidently they
can really add a new dimension to the
style of cooking but the real trick is
finding that balance of flavors that
really suits you because that's the most
important part
so this is the most amazing sirloin you
can see it's got that wonderful marble
for me the secret behind this
is cooking it quickly season the steaks
generously
salt and pepper
push that seasoning in to the sirloin
take the soda out the fridge literally
20 minutes before you want to cook them
so it gets up to room temperature they
cook more evenly but more importantly
you can actually season
right inside
the steak this little bit of fat down
here season that as well because that is
what we want to roast and get that
really nice and rendered olive oil in a
tablespoon
roll that round
as it starts to smoke in with the steaks
into the pan
and lay away
again
into the pan
and lay away if you don't hear that
noise the minute those steaks hit the
pan don't put them in so the secret now
is getting that color on the steak
turning it once and once only and
cooking it for two and a half minutes
each side what i want to do is to get
that bit of fat rendered so it adds a
lot more flavor just hold
the steak down like that
and that starts to melt the fat which
makes it so much more tender there
should be no white fat left anywhere
turn them over
really important to have that steak up
to room temperature before you start
cooking it so the inside is nice and
warm so we spend less time in the pan
and more time cooling down really
important
now two fingers touch
it goes in says rare i'm happy for them
to be rare because by the time i let
them rest
they're going to go back to medium rare
it'll continue cooking
out onto a plate and let them rest
one
to
just get my juices over
don't waste that really important
next the spicy dressing take the seeds
out of the chili to reduce the heat by
rubbing it in your hands and tapping
until the seeds fall out
cut it in half
and just chop it
in
garlic and chilli works brilliantly a
quick way of peeling it get your knife
and just
slam it down
pops out very very quickly in a little
touch of salt
rub
start going around in circles first
you'll see it puring
nice clear that off
now we've got the heat in there from the
chilli and that richness from the garlic
two teaspoons of palm sugar this is
where it starts to have that nice sweet
sour effect
fish sauce
fresh lime this is a simple fresh chili
dressing and it was something i fell in
love with in vietnam and cambodia
because it was just so easy
give that a little mix and dissolve
the sugar
quick taste
wow right vegetables
a great fuss-free way to get super thin
ribbons of carrot is to use a veg peeler
when they're that thin they take the
vinaigrette so much better and radishes
just slice them down at an angle
lovely to give another dimension to the
salad i'm gonna use a banana shallot
they are incredibly mellow
very sweet
across
just chop up
the shallot
and mix that through
want some sweetness in there now little
vine tomatoes slice them
in half smarter's in
shallot radish carrots and tomatoes
next peel and slice cucumber
chopped spring onions and shred baby gem
lettuce and then finally get some fresh
mint
there's young men so you don't need to
take all those stalks off all you do is
hold the bunch upside down and then take
it for a little trim
and just chop that once
through
look at that nice
minted
salad a couple of tablespoons of
dressing don't flood the salad with a
dressing you can always add but we can't
take it away now really mix that
dressing in there make sure all that
chili and garlic and palm sugar wraps
around that salad beautiful
onto the plate the steaks rested it's
now nice and medium rare that little bit
of fat we don't want to find that in the
salad just slice that off that serves
its purpose
it's kept that steak nice and moist
just slice going with the grain it's
almost like
slicing through butter and look inside
beautiful pink you slice the beef too
thinly then it goes stone cold and more
importantly all the goodness runs out of
it
nice thick slices
get the beef and start placing it around
the salad
take a little teaspoon of your dressing
the rest of your salad
sit there on top
and finish it off with some
toasted peanuts peanuts in
now those nuts
are really toasted nuts on
get another pan
and just
crush
once they've cooled down
just run them through with a knife
they can hear how crunchy they are
another
texture another taste the salad
and then from there sprinkle
and then finally
take that
just finish it with a little
tablespoon of that sauce
and there is one tasty very well
textured spicy beef salad
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips
and 100 recipes to stake your life on
and you'll literally be cooking yourself
into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details go on get cooking